hey y'all welcome to my flickers of fear
show movie we're talking about today
this might be
the newest one that i've ever reviewed
but yeah this is one that i've actually
been hearing a lot of buzz about and i
think like one or two of you guys even
uh you know requested that i do this one
if i'm not uh if i'm remembering
correctly
so this is a movie it actually premiered
at sundance in late january of 2022. uh
sundance was actually online this year
so it kind of premiered online then but
then it got picked up by fox searchlight
and then it premiered on hulu which is
where i watched it at the beginning of
march 2022 so this has only been out for
a couple of months
this movie is called
fresh
now as i said i've been hearing a lot of
buzz about this one so i have hulu and i
really really wanted to get around to
watching it
now i will say that this movie
is really
really difficult to talk about without
spoiling it and i will say too that if
you want to watch it um it's much better
going into it not really knowing
what it's about necessarily um it's just
much much better trust me maybe you'll
be able to just from like the one
sentence synopsis that's on hulu maybe
you'll kind of be able to guess like
what direction it's going in
but
i mean i kind of got the vibe of like i
thought i knew where it was going but it
was actually like a little bit different
to what i thought um so that's all i'm
going to say so i'm just saying that if
you want to watch the movie if you have
hulu or if it's on some other streaming
service and you want to hear me talk
about it maybe go watch it first i'm not
going to like spoil anything out right
or the end or anything like that but
there is a pretty big
shift in tone in the movie uh which
takes place uh you know at the end of
the first act which sends the movie off
in a another direction and obviously i'm
probably going to have to say what that
is otherwise i'm not going to be able to
talk about the movie hardly so
just know that going in this is kind of
kind of a spoiler warning
so this movie is actually the
directorial debut of a woman named mimi
cave
and uh this was written by a woman named
lauren khan now there's actually two
quite big stars in this uh daisy edgar
jones who's a british actress although
she plays an american in this uh
probably she's been in a bunch of stuff
but probably best known for the british
miniseries normal people
and this also has sebastian stan in it
uh probably best known for being bucky
barnes and the mcu uh he was in the
martian as well and i didn't even
realize this while i was watching the
[ __ ] movie because he looked so
different but he also played jeff galuli
in i tonya which we just watched like a
week or two ago and it's like while i
was watching fresh i had no idea i was
like oh yeah it's the same dude but now
that i'm thinking about it i'm like oh
yeah but he looked so different in that
that i really couldn't tell like i said
i'm not
i've seen uh he's was in captain america
winter soldier and all that i've seen
some of those but i didn't remember him
from those because i haven't seen all
the mcu and it was a long time ago that
i saw them so i didn't really but yeah
he's like super famous so i have to say
that i like though that they kind of
used him
in a way of this because i from what i
could gather he doesn't i mean i guess
jeff golia was kind of a villain but he
doesn't really play villains but they
actually kind of like used his sort of
like natural charm and charisma uh in
service of like a more horror type thing
going on
so uh i will say that so i and i also
want to say too that the two actors that
are in this the two lead actors uh their
chemistry with one another is really
really good and i think that's one of
the strengths of this movie like why it
makes it work now this movie
okay
i'm gonna say and like i said this
pretty much anything i say about this
movie is gonna be spoilers um if you
know so if you want to watch this movie
it's just better going into it not
really knowing what you're getting into
it's much much better that way i will
say that it is it's not extremely gory
or you know but there is some stuff like
later on it is definitely goes in a
horror direction and it is kind of gory
more like
kind of gross and uncomfortable than
gory but there is some gore in it so
if you're not down with that then know
that going in it does go in like a
pretty [ __ ] up direction like in the
in act two and three um even though it
doesn't seem to start out that way
so that's another kind of thing that you
probably uh should know going into it
so interestingly this movie
it's kind of it's okay it's marketed as
pretty much like a horror comedy or like
a black comedy which it is but
i kind of feel like it's more of a
horror movie
at least in the second two acts than it
is a comedy has some funny [ __ ] in it
and some of the situations are like
blackly humorous
but i wouldn't call it like an overt
comedy it's much more
okay uh the vibe of this is very much
like
american psycho so
if you liked american psycho this has
like a similar type of
thing to it you know what i mean it's
like this similar type of tone it's
really does kind of go like that and i
i'm pretty sure that it's uh
particularly sebastian stan i think he's
sort of
channeling
uh you know christian bale
an american psycho he's not it's not
like a copy but it's like a similar kind
of thing that he's doing a similar kind
of character that he's playing
so at the beginning of the movie it
almost like i said it almost starts
like a rom-com not like a zany rom-com
but just kind of like a romantic type of
movie like with some funny stuff in it
so what you have you have this young
woman
and i think this is set in the pacific
northwest somewhere like washington
state or something
and her name is noah
and she's become very disillusioned with
uh this whole dating jazz especially
like all these apps that she's using and
at the beginning you're kind of
seeing her struggles and i'm sure like
most you know most women that have had
to be like in the dating pool even
before like all the proliferation of
dating apps and stuff will recognize a
lot of the [ __ ] that she's going through
and she's really becoming like
disillusioned with it you know what i
mean it's like at the beginning she's on
a date with a guy who's like doesn't
seem like a bad looking guy or anything
like that but she knows it's gonna be
bad because even before they got to the
restaurant where he's taking it or
dinner he's like bring cash with you and
like all this other kind of stuff so
he's like a little bit uh tacky so she's
on a date with that guy and the guy is
just kind of like not mean but he's just
saying all this stuff that sort of like
sort of like low-key like denigrating
her like oh well you know women of our
parents generation were so much better
they were so much more feminine because
she's just wearing kind of like a
regular sweater or whatever and he's
like you would look really good in a
dress and pull out and he just gets like
dickier and dickier like as the time
goes on and then um you know after
dinner she's just like yeah she pays for
her own food he takes her leftovers it's
like it's yeah he's just very very
gauche
and uh so that date ends and then she's
just kind of like yeah not feeling it um
i don't really want to see you anymore
and then of course he flips out and
calls her stuck up [ __ ] and everything
like that and i was like okay yeah
that's that's about par for the course
um and then they kind of show her going
through some more stuff with
you know somebody uh on her little
dating app or whatever like sending her
a thing with like a picture of their dog
and she's like oh what a cute dog and
blah blah and then he sends her a dick
pic and i'm just like yep again been
there so
so it's just like you know women will
relate
uh so yeah so she's just kind of
gotten to a point where she's like you
know what maybe i'm just better off
alone this is just like i hate all this
it's just too much for me to deal with
she's like i keep meeting all these
[ __ ] losers and i just don't really
know what to do and you know maybe i'll
just be by myself and it'll be fine uh
she also has a best friend named molly
uh who she says they met i think she
says they met like seven years before
like they used to work together but now
like you know she works somewhere else
or whatever um now i will say that the
character of molly i like that they kind
of did this and i think that maybe this
was kind of like a subversion of the
trope because at first
when molly is first introduced i was
like um because the noah character is a
white girl and i was like so when
molly's first introduced i'm like oh my
god are we having like the sassy black
friend trope are we doing that really um
but then as the as the movie goes on
molly gets a lot more like character
depth intros and it ends up being like
one of the heroes of the piece so i
thought that was kind of like a cool
like little subversion because at first
i'm just sitting there going oh man this
is like it's sassy black friend cliche
and it's like all over but actually she
ended up being a really really good uh
character so i like they kind of
subverted that troop a little bit
so you know you know molly's kind of
like commiserating and all this other
kind of stuff she's like you know i'm
just i'm giving up this is like too much
and molly's like well you know i gave up
she goes uh molly's bisexual so she's
like she's dated men in the past but
she's like yeah i kind of gave up on
that dating girls is so much easier uh
so you know they're kind of as i said
commiserating about that
now so one night after like one
particularly disastrous uh whatever
noah's like looking in her fridge and
she's like oh [ __ ] i don't have any food
in there so she goes to like some late
night grocery store or something
while she's in the produce aisle just
like in the cliche it's like oh you know
you meet people in the grocery store uh
she meets this actually really cute
charming dude named steve
and he's you know kind of funny real
charming stuff like that not like
overtly creepy or weird or anything like
that she and he seems like respectful of
her boundaries and you know kind of
self-effacing and stuff like that so
she's just kind of like huh
at first she's just kind of like real
you know what i mean as you would
because she's kind of like gun shy about
everything but after a while she's like
you know what [ __ ] it you know we don't
she's like i didn't even realize that
you could meet people in real life
anymore because everything is like so uh
you know centered around online a dating
apps and stuff and she's like that's
kind of crazy that we just like you know
met online and it's insane
so she um gives him her number and he
waits a few days but then he calls her
they go on a date and they really really
hit it off i mean she admits to him look
i hate this dating thing i hate this
whole you know getting to know you
period it's just really not for me
and he seems to feel the same way so
they seem to have like this really deep
connection
she also finds out that he seems very
financially successful he's a plastic
surgeon and he says yeah i don't just do
boob jobs and stuff like that i also
like do reconstructive surgery like for
people like burn victims and stuff like
that so he seems like the perfect man
and you know
that when somebody seems like the
perfect man then there's gonna be some
really really bad [ __ ] going on and
indeed that is what happens in this
movie uh even her friend molly even says
she's kind of like
as much as she wants noah to be happy
one of the first things that kind of
like uh you know pings her radar is that
the guy doesn't really have a lot of
social media like he doesn't have
twitter he doesn't use it on instagram
or anything like that and she's like
that's a little bit sketchy which yeah
in this day and age it absolutely is
especially someone who's supposedly like
a plastic surgeon you would think that
they would have some kind of social
media presence to find clients or
whatever and the fact that he doesn't
really have that um you know her friend
thinks that's very very weird
but
noah's just kind of like you know he's
he's just a nice man and you know we're
gonna see where this goes you said [ __ ]
it so i'm saying [ __ ] it so they end up
you know they have sex they have leads
and it seems like a great uh thing
now they've been going out together like
it
i'm not real sure how long it's but it's
not like a hugely long time but it's
been like a few dates and stuff and then
he's like let's go away for the weekend
you know she hasn't known him that long
and that seems a little
soon
but not so much so that it would
immediately be like red flags although
again her friend molly is just like wait
now already like where are you going and
all of a sudden like you keep me
apprised of the whole situation and
she's like yeah it'll be fine
and at first it does seem fine like i
said
the first probably 35 minutes of this
is kind of like a rom-com okay
but
right around the
35-38 minute mark uh it goes it veers
wildly into
super over the top like horror territory
okay so just know that guy again
interestingly too and i actually kind of
loved this decision
the movie just starts and i didn't
really notice this the movie just starts
without any title card or you know cast
or anything like that
once the movie
gets to a point where it's going in the
horror direction like 30 i think it's 38
minutes in something like that
then the title comes up like the title
kind of comes across the back and then
like all the cast and everything so
that's i think that's the longest time
i don't remember ever seeing a movie
that you had to wait 38 minutes like to
see the title and stuff and i was just
like i didn't even notice that it wasn't
there at the beginning because i was
just like started to watch the movie and
i just like got into it and then like
when they did that like 35 minutes or 35
38 minutes in like the title comes
across like the background and then like
all the stuff and i was just kind of
like oh that was a neat idea because at
that point you knew
that uh that it was going in a horror
direction you know previously we were
having like a rom-com direction and like
i said you know this is a horror movie
so the first part of it
uh you know which is like a rom-com
you're just kind of the whole time
you're just waiting for the other shoe
to drop because you know something is
gonna go bad you just are not entirely
sure
what it is and once it goes in a horror
direction one of the things that's
really good about this is that once it
goes in that direction everything that
this guy said in the rom-com portion of
the movie has is completely like
re-texturalized re-textualized uh which
i think is like uh really good
so now if you don't want to know
what this dude's [ __ ] secret is
because you knew he had one
uh then please click off now because i'm
about to tell you
his secret is
that he is not only a cannibal
but
he also essentially kidnaps women
and keeps them prisoner like keeps them
alive for a really long time
uh so that he can slowly cut uh hunks of
flesh off of them which he sells to very
very high-end one percenter clients it's
like a small elite group of cannibals
the world over and he's kind of known
for
his choice cuts of woman meat uh so at
any given time he has you know two or
three women down in this because he has
this real remote uh country house and he
has it all set up in the bottom where
it's like kind of a i don't want to say
it's a dungeon because that sounds like
you know a gothic castle or something
it's very it's modern but he has like
essentially like a dungeon style
situation going on in the basement where
he keeps these women alive and just
cuts portions off of them like
you know their leg or part of their butt
or something like that and then like
he'll freeze pack everything and like
mail it out so that's basically what his
secret is
uh which sadly
noah finds out to her detriment and like
i said that's kind of all i want to
spoil that's like the big reveal but
then after that as i said it goes way
more in
a overtly horror direction where you
know it's her and like the other girls
that are trapped in there uh trying to
escape and also molly who suspected
something was like sketch about steve
the whole time uh essentially trying to
like track her down and find out where
she went to so it's kind of like there's
a little bit of focus on her and this
other guy named paul who was an
ex-boyfriend of hers who was a bartender
who actually was the bartender at the
bar where steve and noah had their first
date so he's kind of like you know
helping with situat you know the the
search
so there's a little bit of that going on
like her looking for
uh looking for her friend and then the
rest of it's kind of focused on
noah and steve and like the interaction
between them and her trying to figure
out how the [ __ ] she's gonna get out of
this situation uh so like i said tonally
if you really liked american psycho you
probably really like this as well
because this has like a very very
similar
style to it in the sense that it's like
very blackly comic not super zany and i
think that sebastian stan's performance
while you can tell that he did like take
some inspiration from christian bale in
american psycho it's not like as over
the top as that sebastian stan comes
across in this he's actually very very
good in this he comes across just like a
regular charming dude which in a way
kind of like makes him a lot more
chilling i mean he doesn't really start
losing his [ __ ] until you know with more
toward the end he just comes across as
not even like cold and calculated like
sociopathic or weird or anything like
that he just comes across almost like a
like a normal dude
and it's really kind of disturbing so
there is like a lot of really disturbing
stuff in this especially when
noah kind of hits on the strategy that
she's going to use to maybe like get a
leg up on him and get herself out of
there and like the [ __ ] that she
has to do um
to sort of facilitate that so yeah so
this actually is absolutely worth
watching there's you know i didn't
really have any issues with it i would
have liked i think um a little bit more
done with molly because she was such a
great character i mean she's in it quite
a bit and i did like that they followed
her some like trying to find where her
friend went
so there is that the only there is one
character though that
i guess there's one character that i
would have liked to
spend a little more time with in the
sense that i wanted to explore
what her motivations were and if you've
seen the movie you probably know the
character that i'm talking about it's
just that i think that there was like a
little bit of like hint around like at
what her deal was but i wish they'd gone
a little bit more into that but overall
um i really enjoyed this a lot it's just
like i said it was very very disturbing
and it's really dark but it's also like
kind of funny and kind of [ __ ] up and
it's just like a like a sort of funny
like blackly humorous examination of
like
modern dating
you know just like going the worst
possible way that it could absolutely go
but yeah i mean i found it really really
entertaining like i said the two uh the
two leads were fantastic they really
played off each other very well and just
kind of their whole
the whole dynamic of like their
relationship and their interactions like
made this really really good for me so
like i said starts out as a rom-com
about 38 minutes in goes like right for
the jugular right into horror so like
like i said if you like american psycho
if you liked something like uh that
french movie raw
this was uh kind of similar to that as
well so anything like in that vein that
is more like blackly humorous but also
like kind of twisted and [ __ ] up um if
you're into that kind of stuff then you
will probably like this as well i
enjoyed it quite a bit and that'll do it
for this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one bye